during a recent Boston Red Sox game this
was kind of weird at Fenway Park for
fans were ejected after hanging this
controversial sign check it out
says racism is as American as baseball
now here's the thing the message was a
little confusing some people thought the
sign was sort of Pro racism but the
people who held up the sign said no
their message was actually anti racism
and everyone was confused reading that
sign how is it anti-racist but it was
very confusing what turns out these
particular fans have been writing
confusing signs for a while and
displaying them at Fenway Park look at
some of the ones they wrote these are
crazy look at this ones Mexicans get out
and vote for councilman Pete Gomez look
at this one right here lock her up in a
creative workspace for she can write
more books there's this one hashtag
resist the temptation to speak out
against our president there's this one
save the earth then again think it's too
late I mean that's just there's say no
to neo-nazis the old ones are better
there's I am a snowflake and together we
are an avalanche of course most
avalanches kill innocent people who were
just trying to have fun
and finally magazines are still my go-to
reading source Us Weekly for life
[Applause]
you